so much for bias against right wing on
Twitter additionally Miss navaroli are
you familiar with the account Libs of
tick tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um these people Mr Roth are you familiar
with this account we got the mask in the
background we got the Trump tweets when
was this uh this is this wasn't long ago
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to children
yes I am aware of that and other claims
from the account and are you aware that
this lie was then circulated by other
prominent far-right influencers
yes
and are you aware that all these claims
uh which I have reiterated were false
culminated in a real-life harassment and
ultimately a bomb threat
to the Boston Children's Hospital
yes I am aware and this account is still
on that platform today isn't it all
right why would the account get deleted
if one crazy person makes a bomb threat
yeah what does that have to do with
anything what about all and she's
talking about that they're posting lies
what about every single BLM case that
was taken out of context and burned
cities down over this is the same woman
who was also saying that the hunter
Biden laptop story is isn't important
and what is important about that is that
former Twitter executives are now
admitting to suppressing the New York
Post story about Hunter Biden laptop
which has all kinds of evidence about
his business dealings and how when his
father was vice president they were all
making money and he was using his
father's influence as vice president in
order to make business dealings in China
he was getting paid hundreds of millions
of dollars even though he was snorting
crack off of hooker's asses in the
meantime yeah yeah yeah bottom G and so
she and it amounts to election
interference so full investigation is
going on there may be arrests in the
future we don't know we're waiting to
see but she's saying that election
interference doesn't matter so this is
the same woman who has zero zero
credibility in my eyes regrettably yes
it is
regrettably hold on let me rewind that
that's so funny and this account is
still on that platform today isn't it
yes it is please despite inspiring this
dude looks like he has his dick tucked
but beneath his legs are you looking at
if they were doing if they're actually
doing it so I'm on the Boston Children's
Hospital website I used to give them
donations and I stopped because they're
mutilating children okay so it says
gender affirming hysterectomies
including ovarian sparing hysterectomies
and hysterectomies down in coordination
with phalloplasty
mettoid ioplasty we only perform gender
affirming hysterectomies on patients who
are 18 or older so that's what they say
on their website there were accusations
that they were doing it on girls as
young as 16. Haram we don't know for
sure a bomb threat due to the right wing
incitement of violence against trans
Americans in this country stop for a
second stop for a second so she's going
to keep going right wing right wing
right wing and divisive divisive
divisive when the true facts are even in
Independence and Democrats except for
the progressive loons are not against or
excuse me are fully against the child
grooming and child mutilation so this
isn't a right-wing loon thing in a bomb
threat is well yeah but that's that's
not even a right-wing thing that's just
being a crazy person that's just being a
crazy person right every large audience
you know if you have a hundred thousand
people seeing each tweet even if only
0.01 of it that's like what 10 people I
see crazies on take on Twitter all day
long I I mean I've got trolls following
me around like saying the most horrible
things to me on Twitter and I'm just
like whatever no matter what you say
there's always going to be someone that
agrees there's gonna be a crazy person
that misunderstands it like there's you
can never just please everyone it's not
a thing it's scientifically impossible
but she never called out Chuck Schumer
when he when he threatened Brett uh
Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh
she never called in out Maxine Waters
when Maxine Waters said to you know
surround Republicans and harass them so
these are actual elected officials
telling people to it's like actually
telling people to harass people they
disagree with and endanger them she
never called them out but Libs of tick
tock this tweet she brings to the
Congressional floor you kidding me AOC
people are dealing with crime in your in
in your District in this country and
you're she's such a weird like what goes
on in that he brain of hers and
everyone's like she graduated from
Boston University blah blah blah and I'm
here to tell you I graduated from Boston
University and it's a [__] easy
school so it's not College college isn't
hard let's not make it like she's some
kind of Genius when you have like the
exact road map laid out in front of you
of what you need to do like you know I
need to do this assignment I need to do
this assignment that shit's not hard I'm
sorry yeah it's hard like you have to do
the work but you don't have to think and
like find ways to to problem solve on
your own or come up with like new
strategies like every single thing that
I do it's like I just think of it and
I'm like okay I have to do this this and
this I don't have someone telling me
like assignments you know what I mean
yeah it's it's a totally different ball
game so that's why and that's our first
time it's harder than others it depends
on your mind is relative though right it
is relative what I'm saying but I'm just
telling you overall sorry to my fellow
bu Alum it's not that hard so let's not
everyone's like she's so smart no she's
not there's thousands of people that
that graduate from each College each
year every single year it's not that
[__] hard man yeah only so many
people that can she was that smart she
would have come out of BU and not been a
bartender okay let's go even getting
into schools that shit's all just so
stupid bro they picked you from like SAT
scores and an essay that nobody wants
the SAT is racist what's wrong with you
yeah we're partnering up with a Navy
SEAL friend of ours Tom Shea hosts a 21
day virtual event that you guys can join
with us Tom is going to teach you how to
listen to your mind in a new way and how
to control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want so I've seen this process done
for 30 years when you make it through
you will be a different human being the
process is simple but not easy because
of the war that's inside of us the few
people have been taught to fight
overcoming your excuses so if you're
interested in becoming a reform human an
absolute animal go to tomshay.com and
use Sunny fast50 for 50 off of this
program you will not regret it you will
be a changed person at the end of it do
not miss this right wing incitement of
violence against trans Americans
because they cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LG so boring
herself and it's so it doesn't mean it
yeah but this is what the leftists eat
up to it's we live in such a clown world
this is what the leftist watch eat up
and then they're like yeah I'm I'm on
the right side of History defending the
the trans people and inciting violence
against trans and LGBT people in
addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color
love yourself in there yeah yeah you're
in Congress you're in one of the most
powerful seats on Earth talking about
how oppressed you are give it a rest
pumpkin you're not oppressed how did the
country possibly get worse after Obama
was President wouldn't you think after a
black man becomes president and shows
that like this supposedly like super
oppressed group is now like the leader
of the Free World you think that would
have just been squashed right it was a
rug pill like we talked about it was a
rug pull they tricked him into thinking
that everything was going to get great
and it doesn't because what it proves
what it proves is that your life is your
personal responsibility and if you spend
all you put all your focus on what's
wrong what's wrong what's wrong that's
all you're gonna see is what's wrong
people of color all your focus on
getting better looking for an
opportunity take an opportunity all
you're going to see is Improvement
opportunity and growth that is the
problem and these people are victim
victim victim I think that victim
mentality should become an officially
designated mental disease yeah because I
really do think it's a it's a mental
disorder at this point you know you do
also have a lot of microaggressions and
if you heard of the microaggressions
yeah that shit's so funny give me I
can't think of one right like you're
you're pretty for a we could honestly
watch that next comment if you want to
see a video reacting to microaggressions
and use the past hour of this committee
and of Congress in order to pursue a
political agenda I yield back wait wait
what did she just say that somebody's
using the power of this committee to
pursue a political agenda violence
against trans and LGBT people in
addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color they really do have to
just lump it all together they can't
just have you can't just do one at a
time it's got to be trans
trans people people of color immigrants
like we just hate every we just hate
everybody that's not what did she get a
phone call like if she if she only talks
about trans people to all the women of
color uh call her and be like hey excuse
me uh you forgot to mention us today
she just God insufferable this is a
party that cannot pick on anyone their
own size
and they are trying to are you saying
they can't pick on anything are you
saying we're bigger guys
and they are trying to co-opt an entire
social media platform and use the power
of this committee and of Congress in
order to pursue a political agenda did
you just say that she accused the
Republicans of trying to push a
political agenda in the power of with
the power of congress that is all you do
you crazy lunatic look in the mirror I
can't with is she posting she gets me so
mad because she's so stupid yeah she's
literally doing exactly what she just
said and the account is just posting
tweets and this is you want you want
everyone banned that doesn't agree with
you everyone that you don't like well
it's not that it's not that she she's
not asking to ban them because no
because misinformation that's why right
because because she disagrees she is
asking to ban them because she says what
they said was untrue well if that's the
case she should be fighting to have the
president impeached and she should be
fighting to have the president taken off
Twitter because half the [__] he said in
the State of the Union Address earlier
this week was absolute capping absolute
happening straight cap straight cap so
let's see if she applies that standard
to herself and the president which she
won't piss off AOC peace off are you
British all right thank you guys so much
for watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz join
the Discord if you want a free preview
of how I've generated all my money
online totally free and I'll see you
inside later hey come meet me on Twitter
let's fight together
gone
[Music]